it's midday just seven hours left for
the teams to create their pop-up
restaurants back at base the taking
delivery of their furniture and crockery
Oh Paco we've had it now Susan's out of
depth they need to understand her pop-up
is a one-night-only mega experience and
this is it show off create those
fireworks because that's what's going to
make your restaurant win this
competition upstairs
I get the sense that posh boys Sam and
Eddie haven't been to Ikea before and
didn't realize that their eight natural
wood tables come flat packs go take us
an hour
downstairs pack on susana working on the
finishing touches I was expecting this
morning all why is this going to even
look like a dining room but we're
getting there slowly with no time to
spare someone Eddie finally master flat
pack tables but it still captures what
we are about and pleased with what we
dealt with it I can't believe that we've
actually made this horrible room looking
so where are you mother
yeah over there just we are there some
you know it's been it's been a close-run
thing this afternoon but we sorted
it's seven o'clock queues of hungry
diners wait to be seated small elastic
spray from scratch - stunning
restaurants yeah for bare walls - empty
shells one kitchen
the pressures on guys and in three hours
time one restaurants leaving this
competition and one restaurant is don't
true the final they have just three
hours to impress with a thrilling
one-off dining experience and that
experience should start as soon as
people walk in
of a pop-up restaurant stroller
hey Kasmir restaurant check on tape
you've got the first order in five
minutes
Susan you feelin okay Wow oh she's
smiling I have to say I'm impressed I've
had my doubts where the mum Susan can
run a restaurant with a firm hand but
tonight she seems determined to prove me
wrong
they'll come together at the right time
and we know it's not your size how you
finished but great [ __ ] style come on
kid this young girl in russian casa mia
are already busy taking orders leaving
phyno playing catch-up thank you chick
corn but as their first orders reach the
kitchen already there's a problem